thank you good afternoon everyone the
European Green Deal is the face of this
commission and I am sure that in a few
years time people will look back and
will speak about a pre Green Deal era
and a post Green Deal era
it's a generally a transformative agenda
and if we implement and use it properly
it will deliver the change that Europe
and this planet needs the ambition and
change must have a clear guidelines in
very concrete measures this is what we
discussed today first of all conclusions
on biodiversity united the Commission
the parliament and now the council in
our common determination to turn
ambition into practical change ministers
of member states have asked to set
biodiversity goals targets and
implementation measures themselves
clearly there is an ambition to
mainstream protection and restoration of
essential ecosystems into sectoral
policies the conclusions are very strong
on this question which is very positive
while we do we do need protected areas
most of the damage is done in areas that
are not protected and that is where we
should concentrate our efforts the
conclusions underline the need for
transformative change for safeguarding
and improving the state of biodiversity
and ecosystems at all levels and for
reinforcing ecosystem resilience and
restoration while avoiding ecosystem
degradation the outline a path that will
help Europe lead with a new biodiversity
strategy for the next 10 years enabling
us to set the pace in coming China next
autumn when the Convention on
biodiversity holds its 15 Conference of
the parties our credibility on the world
stage will depend on our domestic
approach these conclusions are the basis
on which we need to craft that approach
in this context we have today also touch
on deforestation and the importance of
protecting old-growth forests in
particular forests will form an
important part of our work in preparing
the 2030 biodiversity strategy and 2020
we will see more actions to protect
Ecosystem both India and abroad
secondly we move forward with
preparations to deliver our zero
pollution ambition fitness checks on
Europe's air and water legislation
indicated that legislation in both areas
is working well but that there is still
plenty of room for improvement the
agreement on water between European
Parliament and the council allow us to
address emerging threats like endocrine
disrupters and micro plastics in water
it goes further than standards of World
Health Organization and that's how it's
supposed to be everyone should feel safe
about drinking water
moreover the importance of a new
chemical strategy for sustainability was
also discussed as we must ensure the
toxic-free environment that citizens
deserve it was a day of evaluation and a
day that allowed us to prepare for the
next year when we will deliver on the
way on different actions and initiatives
outlined in the European Green Deal
which will be a true game changer I
would like to truly thank to the Finnish
presidency they did amazing job and they
put environmental agenda very very top
of the council and gender and of course
let me seize the opportunity and wish
you all a very Merry Christmas together
with your families and loved ones thank
you